هناك امور متناقضه حقيقه نشهدها في
الميدان لذلك سنبدا من شمال قطاع غزه شمال
قطاع غزه كانت قد قالت اسرائيل قبل نحو
اسبوع انها قوضت من وجود حركه المقاومه
كتائب القسام تحديدا في المنطقه الشماليه
وامس قالت انها سحبت اعداد من جنودها
اعداد كبيره من جنودها والياتها اليوم
تعود الاشتباكات الى منطقه جباليا ومخيم
جباليا عند الاطراف بحسب الاعلام
الاسرائيلي قوات الاحتلال اضطرت الى اعاده
ارسال قوه خاصه للتعامل مع ما رصدته بحسب
صحيفتها ارتس من ان حركه حماس كتائب
القسام تمكنت من
اعاده ترميم البنيه العسكريه لها في
المنطقه الشماليه وانها عينت قاده جدد
للكتائب المقاتله في شمال القطاع الفارق
بين تصريحين لا يتجاوز سبعه ايام بين
القول بان الحركه او الكتائب القسام لم
تعد موجوده في الشمال والانسحاب واليوم
اعاده الدفع بقوه لتتوج وتشتبك مع
المقاومين وسجلت ايضا بحسب مراسلينا
الميدانيين ان سماع انفجار كبير بالقرب من
مدينه غزه في شمال المنطقه عفوا في جنوب
المنطقه الشماليه سننتقل الى المنطقه
الوسطى كانت محورا قتاليا عنيفا خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه محاور القتال لا
تزال تقريبا ثابته في البريج والنصيرات
والمغازي وهناك قصف عنيف تتعرض له مدينه
دير البلح القوات الاسرائيليه كانت على
مدى الايام الماضيه تحاول التوغل الى داخل
دير البلح ولكن هناك مقاومه شديده لكن ما
يجري في الجنوب يبقى العنصر الاكثر قوه في
الجنوب لا تزال الاشتباكات عند منطقه
خانيونس ولا تزال ايضا التمركزات
الاسرائيليه من الشمال ومن جنوب المدينه
واشتباكات عنيفه واستهداف من قبل كتائب
القسام لجنود يتمركزون في احد الابنيه في
هذه المنطقه يجب ان نذكر شيء معهد
الدراسات العسكريه الحديثه والحروب الحديث
الامريكي التابع
ل هيئه الاركان الامريكيه كان قد تحدث عن
ان المشكله التي ستواجه حركه او ستواجه
عمل الجيش الاسرائيلي داخل قطاع غزه هي
الانفاق لان الانفاق ليس هناك من معلومات
واضحه وكافيه عن تواجدها وحجمها امس كان
هناك حديث امريكي اسرائيلي عن وجود مفاجاه
في ثلاثه مراحل بما يتعلق بموضوع الانفاق
على مستوى نوعيه هذه الانفاق على مستوى
انتشار هذه الانفاق فاق وايضا على مستوى
امتداد هذه الانفاق تصفها صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز نقلا عن مصادر امريكيه واسرائيليه
بانها غير مسبوقه في الحروب الحديثه حتى
في الحروب التي شهدت استخداما للانفاق او
البنيه التحتيه للمدن للقتال منها وهنا
الاكاديميه الامريكيه التابعه لويست بوينت
تتحدث عن وقوع اشتباكات في مناطق اخرى وفي
حروب اخرى لم يكن فيها انفاق ولكن تم
استخدام البنيه التحتيه لتلك المدن على
سبيل المثال الانفاق الخاصه بمياه الصرف
الصحي او المياه لقتال الجيوش النظاميه
المفاجاه هذه التي اعلنت عنها صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز تترافق ايضا مع مجموعات
اخرى من الاخبار تتحدثوا عن ان
هناك عدم امكانيه بشكل كامل ل انهاء وجود
كتائب المقاومه وكتائب القسام في مناطق
قطاع غزه وهناك مياده في هذا الصدد نسمع
اي جدلا اسرائيليا على المستويات السياسيه
وحديثا عن ان اي انسحاب في هذه اللحظات
وفي هذه الاثناء من مناطق القطاع سيعد
خساره استراتيجيه لقوات الاحتلال